well today we're going to be speaking
with Mike cargile Mike cargile is
running for congress in California's
35th congressional district uh I believe
Mike you're the only Congressional
candidate this cycle who it has been
unendorsed by the Republican party is
that is that a correct credential that
you have
Yes actually I am the only Congressional
candidate in the nation who's been
unendorsed twice now by the Republican
party for being what they consider too
conservative so give me any was there
communication did they tell you on what
issues you're just too far to the right
no actually they scroll we a few weeks
ago they had an unendorsement meeting of
their board of directors yeah and they
said here you've got two minutes to talk
and I said talk about what what do you
want to talk about and they said well
watch this and they rolled four minutes
of memes off of Facebook that go all the
way back to 2018 and I knew where this
came from because this was how George
Soros had attacked me in the last cycle
oh Soros is going after you he has and
and so the Republican parties using the
Soros Playbook uh he came after me with
Media Matters and axios last time would
you say Soros has infiltrated the
Republican establishment at this point
yes
wow yes so they uh they came after me
and tried to now remember back in 2020
this was the world of BLM riots and
things like that so he had Unearthed a a
conversation a private conversation I
had had with a friend of mine
about the use the the prevalent use of
the n-word in rap music and I said
that's all you know so we're typing this
out and I said that's all they're doing
right now is building the songs around
the n-word and I typed the N word out
expressing you know my concern because
I'm not a word you would ever use other
than citing it of course correct correct
but but you have when you're having a
conversation in messenger you have to
type it out right and so they found this
and said oh look he's a racist he's
using the n-word and that was the
narrative and the New York Times picked
it up LA Times Boston you know
everywhere suddenly because of the
environment at that time well that is so
Mike I don't want to let this slip
because this is mind-blowing George
Soros who at the time of I guess when
this happened was 90 I think he's 92 now
90 year old George Soros
obtained a private text communication
that you had with someone else else
bemoaning the use of the n-word in rap
music is that right yes wow that is an
incredible story and then they they take
it and they go look see white guy writes
out the n-word and he's a racist and
then you know then might just sort of
cascade and that's it's almost
unbelievable to be perfectly Frank I
think many in my audience will struggle
to believe that well it's what happened
and it was what was regurgitated by the
California Republican party a couple
weeks ago well as as further evidence
and they they said publicly in their
meeting uh anyone can can look this up
because it's all over the internet now
what they did to me but but they said
how did this guy make it through the
primary we unendorsed him in 2020 and
here he is again and we're having to
unendorse him again
just as a gut check we're doing this
when we speak to 2022 candidates and
it's a weird question to ask but I hope
you'll indulge me who is the real
president of the United States right now
well who's sitting in the white house
that's the that's you know that's Joe
Biden right was he there legitimately I
don't know let's find out I'm the I'm on
a lawsuit that's at the ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals right now our oral
arguments will begin September 23rd and
we're asking to forensically audit 13
counties in California most important
lawsuit in the nation isn't and I want
to get to the bottom of this question
because people go he's not legit he is
legit it was stolen it wasn't stolen
folks nobody knows hold on a second Mike
let's see if we can break that down
though because so nobody knows we have
we have results from California right
the results from California are Biden
got 11.1 million votes Trump got six
million votes overwhelming victory for
buy those are the results we have in
order to say we don't know we should
have some reason to question those
results what reason do you have to
question the results that make you say I
can't be confident that we have the real
numbers well David if you were an
Olympian and you ran a race and you got
the gold medal let's say you're like
Usain Bolt you were in this race you got
the gold medal yep what's the first
thing they do after you set that world
record
they do a blood test okay and they they
check to see if you have a performance
enhancing drugs in your system okay
that's an audit they do an audit of your
bloodstream why don't we do the same
thing with the greatest race in the
world which is the U.S presidential
election well I think one reason would
be
just the voter registration numbers in
California are so lopsided towards
Democrats that it's very hard to believe
that there would be any real outcome
there other than Biden easily winning I
mean let me ask you a question what do
you suspect were the real results in
California
I don't know okay no but but it's a
cop-out to say you don't know what
reason do you have to question the
results
thousands and thousands of affidavits
that have been submitted to my
coplaintiff under you know the notarized
and uh you know the charge of perjury if
you lie on this that they saw things
that were not right conducted in a
myriad of places including the polling
places including ballot drop-off boxes
nobody knows and yet no one wants to
look and all I'm asking with my
coplaintiffs is let's open the hood and
let's actually see what occurred okay
when you look at the voter registration
numbers
even if there were tens of thousands or
even hundreds of thousands of these
instances right
California only 24 percent of registered
voters are Republicans there's just no
way Trump could have won well I'm not
I'm not saying that I'm saying that did
you know this okay there are there are
2.8 million more registered voters in
California than there are citizens no
that is absolutely untrue I we've got
the data to prove it I hope you will
send it to me my co-oplaintiff is the
election Integrity project California
okay and they will listen because I
don't have I mean we did I've not seen
that I mean send it to me send it to me
you know every state in which it has
been claimed that there are more voters
than citizens it has been it has been
debunked and it seems in California it
wouldn't be even close has any state
done a forensic audit well the states
have done all sorts of evaluations and
recounts and audits but then someone
always comes hold on but Mike hold on
hold on hold on yes go ahead someone
then comes along and and says that's not
the type of audit I meant
no they've done recounts nobody has done
an audit space in Arizona an audit was
done and it found Biden got even more
votes the the Arizona audit was not done
properly
what we're what we're looking for is
this we have three things in our
complaint yeah here's the ballot I want
to look at the envelope and then let's
look at the machine okay they've had to
look at the um they've safeguarded the
images of the the hard drives we have
the voter rolls and let's compare all
four of those all right well let's do
that we're not going to be able to do it
today so in the interest we can start
today we can say no I mean you and I
won't be able to now listen I want to
ask you something there's this guy who
we my audience knows him as Mike pillow
he's the CEO of my pillow Mike Lindell
but as a shorthand we'll sometimes call
him Mike pillow or even just pillow
everybody knows who he is he is obsessed
with the machines and he actually wants
to sue every machine
are you where are you on the machines
well I think the machines need to be
looked at okay I think just like
denester's movie with uh 2 000 mules the
ballot drop-off boxes need to be looked
at
um one of the one of the areas in our
lawsuit is the article 4 section four of
the U.S Constitution it's called the the
guarantee clause and the federal
government is supposed to guarantee that
we are free from foreign Invasion but it
doesn't say how the foreign invasion is
conducted and right now we have no
safeguards in California election law to
say China can't submit 30 million
ballots and we have no way to safeguard
against it when they under the guise of
covet have removed all the safeguards in
place but Mike do you have reason to
believe China submitted 30 million
ballots it's very easy to say I can't
prove to you that it wasn't done you
can't prove to me it wasn't done but you
have reason to believe China submitted
30 million ballots I've seen no such
evidence I I don't need the evidence I
have the Constitution which says any law
that allows China to do this is
unconstitutional
because it allows for foreign Invasion
whether it's at The Ballot Box or the
shoreline how can China submit 30
million ballots when you have to be an
American citizen in order to even
register to vote how is that even
possible because you can do it through
the ballot boxes no verification needed
in California you can have same-day
voter registration you don't have to
vote you can literally walk in on
November 8th and say I've never voted in
my life before and I'd like a ballot
right but if you're walking in and
voting that then you're an American
citizen who who is registering to vote
how is China doing that they can do it
at the they can do it through the boxes
the drop-off boxes see they can't deny
any ballot they receive up until the
close of business November 8th right but
then they look at it and if it's not a
registered if it's not if it's not a
citizen then it's an invalid how do they
know it's not a citizen there's no
checks in place you don't know they're
not even allowed to ask for ID they
don't know if you're a citizen a
non-citizen in California this is the
thing David Mike Mike Mike there were 17
million votes in California okay just
just hear out the numbers there were 17
million votes in California Biden got
11. Trump got six when you talk about
any one Ballot Box and you talk about
China and 30 million ballots and on and
on even if I grant you that every one of
your thousands of affidavits is bona
fide proof of some fraud right bona fide
proof when the popular when the voting
public is only 17 million people how on
Earth do you think that they're going to
be able to slip by this number of
fraudulent fake whatever votes and only
a few thousand people submit affidavits
it but it's impossible to believe that
well then would you join me in calling
for an audit of the system so I I see
there's no reason to audit this there's
just the numbers don't add up there's no
reason to audit it no if you won the
gold medal we would automatically audit
the race okay well there should be
Olympic Olympic 100 meter dash is not
voting did you have no I mean Mike that
doesn't make any sense it sounds silly
it makes total sense because any
competition in the United States if Tom
Brady uses an under inflated football
yeah we almost tear the country apart
why don't we do that for the greatest
competition in the land which this
sounds so silly though Mike it sounds
silly I don't know that this is going to
win you the 35th District I'm not sure
well I'm not trying to to you know
please somebody I'm trying to say let's
get to the bottom of this issue so that
we can all be comfortable with U.S
elections once again most people are
comfortable that's the thing when you
pull people most people are comfortable
no that's not true what poll do you have
well the poll of my district and I can I
can show you that by the amount of
people who wait to go to the polling
locations because they don't trust
that's not a problem most people just
vote on Election Day that doesn't mean
they don't trust another system listen
Mike we don't have unlimited time
there's a really other important thing I
want to ask you about because I read
this about you do you believe that a
satanic cabal is in charge of the United
States
I think there's a satanic cabal running
the world hmm
yes and and when you say that like Davos
and the world economic forum who are
some of the satanic individuals
well you've seen a few of them already
they're they're they're not hiding it
you look at any profile high profile uh
rap artist uh you you know from the
Clinton Camp I believe Barack Obama has
been involved in some of it but you look
at that sorosis you look at the
Rockefeller types
um but then but then can but Mike let's
really I want because sometimes people
are so vague Rockefeller types so I mean
let me just ask you is George Soros
demonically or satanically possessed
I don't know you don't know is Barack
Obama
I don't know but you just listed both of
them have you ever asked them no I've
not spoken I've never asked them but who
am I right but what I'm saying is I can
only look at their actions and do you
believe that their actions are evidence
of satanic possession
I don't know but then why are you
bringing their names up because they're
trying to destroy Humanity okay who are
the Rockefeller types you mentioned
well you've seen them I'm not going to
get into to name dropping right now I'll
we'll deal with that later on who will
deal with it though it seems we would
want to know if you have the list I want
to know who these people are well if you
would get me the the uh Jeffrey Epstein
Glenn Maxwell list I could probably
point to a lot of them Mike I got to ask
you a serious question here and I hope
you don't take offense
are most of these satanically possessed
people either black or Jewish because
you're naming a lot of black and Jewish
people
I don't know their ethnicity
you don't know Obama's ethnicity well I
is he
I don't know what what she claims to be
one thing and he's but he's also playing
uh claims publicly to be another thing
what do you mean
well is he a U.S citizen is he an
African citizen is he you know you know
this gives back to the whole you know
birth certificate argument oh my God I
don't I don't have a an opinion on it I
just know that this man has has
presented himself to be one way and then
his actions were entirely another way
he's been the most divisive uh
hate-filled President we probably had
ever had until Joe Biden which is really
Joe you know Obama 3.0 wow so you don't
know what what about Soros and Epstein
did you know that they're they're Jewish
I I don't care
you don't I don't care I don't care what
they are I'm judging them by their
actions or the content of the character
than the color of the skin
so it seems a very superficial argument
to bring in can satanic possession be
cured
well if you remove the possessor I guess
so yeah how is that done though well
biblically it would be through an
exorcism or something of that nature wow
that sounds extremely serious
well are you demonically possessed not
that I'm aware of do I seem it to you no
oh well I'm just saying it sounds like
an exorcism is very serious well I would
say that anyone who's bent on destroying
the human race yeah is probably in
League with the one that you would say
is the enemy of the human race and that
would be Satan himself
wow this is bumming me out Mike I'm not
gonna lie this is a sad Outlook it's
it's making me uh sad about about
Humanity but but look what just occurred
David yeah we got assaulted by a virus
and then a vaccine we were misled by
we've got a green new deal that's going
to destroy and collapse the U.S economy
and that's just the U.S look at what's
going on in Europe looked what's going
on in Asia it's a concerted effort to
thin the world of humans dear God and
then but now on the other end of that
what's the goal why thin the world of
humans who benefits
well if you see people like you and I
yeah in God's image as your enemy well
then then you know that's a victory for
you
you just get rid of the of the bad
people essentially and enough to have
sort of an army of slaves which is if
you take communism at its truest form
that's just a small group of people
controlling a very large group of people
through fear and dependency so we're
looking at a world of slaves that's
being run by a few people
and they're okay they seem to be okay
with slavery as long as they get to be
the new Masters and that's where your
your color component comes in because
it's really not color dependent it's who
gets to play the master this time around
and we have I believe more slaves now in
the United States because of our open
Southern border and our ports of Entry
being wide open than we've ever had and
my opponent is one of the chief wow
Chief uh you know supporters of the wide
open border and I believe is responsible
for a lot of the human trafficking that
has come out of particularly Guatemala
but well Mike listen I have not seen
evidence of that I will investigate it I
have to say in total honesty
some of this stuff is pretty out there
even for the Republican party so I sort
of understand the unendorsement this is
this is some pretty out there stuff that
you're you're saying but just saying
it's out there doesn't mean it's not
true it just means you haven't come to
terms with it that's absolutely correct
that's absolutely correct and I think we
would all benefit if we would all call
for three things and that's that they
would release the Jeffrey Epstein tapes
okay and they would release the Glenn
Maxwell list you know how do you how do
you get charged I want to see that list
sure I know with human trafficking but
but there's no perpetrators we're the
you know you've got the victims but you
don't have the perps and then it just
join me in calling for an audit of the
election system so we can put the issue
to bed if Joe Biden was fairly elected I
would be the first guy to say okay now
we've got our our marching orders let's
fight against it but if we're not if
we're not gonna look under the hood and
see what happened yeah yeah then we're
we're supporting cheating
well Mike cargile you've really said it
all we are going to be very closely
watching that race in the 35th
congressional district and I can't thank
you enough for really giving our
audience uh a lot to think about a lot
to chew on for sure I appreciate your
time
thanks for having me on David anytime
I'm uh I'm an open book and if you want
to talk about anything I think that's
the greatest problem right now in the
United States is where everyone's
yelling at each other we must talk we
must talk we must talk and we can
disagree but we need to do so with civil
discourse